You can review the log of command entered by going to the history
so that would be panel two. Help documentation appears in the lower right
hand side which would be panel four. To clear the work space you
can either use panel two or panel three. You can run a command
in here to clear the work space or you can use the icon
located in panel two. It should look like a sweeping broom. We can
run a bunch of commands from a file from panel one. Plots appear
down here in the lower right, so that would be panel four, and
all of our objects and memory appear up here, in
our environment or our work space. So that's panel two. And
finally to read the results from functions or from calculations, we
simply look at the console, where our output comes, panel three.